2018年
ぼく何を一番頑張りましたかって聞かれたら迷わず
こう答えるでしょう
パズドラー
こちらです僕の今年やってたことを大きく含めて3つほどありますひとつでへ外れ社長
の叩きを作る
これもまあ登録者が100万にいってまぁいい感じだなって思いますた爪
お肉禁止それも今のところお肉全くは食べてません
早く2019になるのが楽しみです
ビックいて3つ目外れ社長の畑て言ってるんですけどもはず空の年来目標
ランクっていうのを決めましてパズドラのランクレベルみたいなのがあるんですけども
経験値で上がっていくそのランクの目標が
線っていう設定だったんですけどもアズラのランク先発らーやってない人から聞いたら
ちょっとよくわかんないと思うんでちょっと
導電くらいなのかちょっと説明させていただきましょう知恵袋にもある
パズドラのランク戦ってすごいですかって質問に対してですね答えが溢れてるけど
少ないです
0.1パーセントもいないかもしれない別にパズがやってる人の中の0.1パーセント
ぐらいしかランク出せな人っていないよっていうぐらいのそのレベルです
ちなみにですね8ラン
苦戦になるために必要な経験値は44
1000万の経験値が必要らしいです津波にランク999から南9線に上がる時に必要
な経験値は1億1千万円まあこれ何かっていうとランクが上がっていくことが必要な
経験値も多くなっていくんですよ南砺市から南くんに見するのはすぐなんですけども
ランク999からなんて線に数何も
[音楽]
あってくらい多いということですね市から南9線まであると思うんですけども折り返し
地点
44くらいの経験積んだと思うんですけども22億折り返しがとかって言われると
975とかそれぐらいらしいですだからね後輩とか友達とか色んな人を目標ランクキビ
だけですよ900とか800とか
600500色色決めたんですけど僕だけです
ん
ちょ待て取り返せ971個っていうことを知らなかったねえ要するに僕だけ他の人たち
より倍以上
パズドラをやんなきゃいけないという中
なんと12月3日をもちまして無事
アンク戦になることができました
[拍手]
4日
rnd
本当に後藤せパンツ撮らスターしてないんですよ
こっちにパズドラしかしてないといいですねあの僕の今年のもう一つの目標数等の
ランク戦にいくっていうのは本当にキリキリ
もう12月入ってやっとカットクリアすることができましたご覧ください
ランク
戦でございますちなみにあのランク戦になれなかったら僕来年坊主でした
前方のランク鮮度を受けたてていいからパズラースゴやってる方から言われるんですよ
無理とかそれは無謀と
やってるんだよ
て家にばして正直に話しだそう今年
シノン煮汁ような時間はずドラのランク上げに主権を使っておりましてはじめ主張です
いやあの本当にねランク戦いって人僕本当に改めて尊敬しますたまに経験値が6倍の時
が有るんでそういう時はもう本当に出ればもう死んでやってました
まあホントどうやってせず店
いうかわかんないですけどランク戦ってね本当にすごいんですよ photos 1年
ゲームの年だなって思います全然甘くないんですよねイズルが伴ってないんですけども
あのう
きつかっ
[音楽]
結果が
欠陥があった
が食ってん
[音楽]
関東管区
bang 線になりました
あの実力は全然見合ってないんですよむしろ下手です下手なんですけども
ランク高いゴール僕はパズドラーがうまいと思ってないんですよ
ランク高いコールはず雷の間使いそれだけです
ラン高くてうまい人もいればランク高くと下手な人がいる
だが愛はあるんですもう
オッパイ揉んでみたいなりましたけど愛はあるんですよ
というわけでほんと素晴らしいゲームに入ってあって極めてはいないんですけども何か
一つに集中してやり込むっていう相当な根性がないとできないと思ってるんだよなぁ縁
達成できて本当によかったウットだけ本当にあなんか下に協力してくださった後輩と
同じ
そして twitter
皆様ありがとうございましたアドバイスとかいろいろいただいてようやくなくてになれ
たのであの
無理って言ってた人じゃ見え
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
お菓子まあもちろん水んですよそっくりなんですかあの実はですねー
ランク戦行きました
くっコメディさーああネットねああ
そうですねーちゃいました売っちゃいました落としちゃったもいい
ラン pics ぐらいだったんですけど
多分まだ700とかですねー
能面今後ともよろしくに入れる負けしてますか